foreign
[Music]
the largest land animal ever to tread
the surface of the Earth was a sole
reporter
they were enormous
some like dreadnaughters could grow to
85 feet long
others tipped the scales at a hundred
tons
that's 10 times heavier than the biggest
elephant
so why were the dinosaurs so much bigger
than their modern counterparts
[Music]
there have been a lot of strange ideas
about why dinosaurs could have gotten so
big one of my favorites was that gravity
has changed through time and maybe the
gravity of the Earth was lower in the
past which meant that the animals got
correspondingly larger
it's an interesting idea but an idea
that's very definitely nonsense the
Earth's gravity has not changed that
much in the last few hundred million
years
one thing we do know is that dinosaurs
could grow fast
[Music]
they grew from an egg the size of a
grapefruit to an absolutely enormous
animal and we have some evidence that
they grew very very very quickly
throughout their early life
gross patterns in fossilized Bones show
some sauropods got to full size in just
20 years
that's an extraordinary thousand-fold
increase
so how did they do it
the sauropods were to some extent
pre-adapted to be able to let them get
really really big
they had a metabolism that was probably
quite like that of birds which allows
them to take oxygen on the in-breath but
also on the out breath
the evidence for that is all of the
holes that we see in the vertebrae and
also in their limb bones
these holes contained air sacs crucial
for extracting oxygen to power their
super efficient metabolism
[Music]
but the holes had another row
the biggest land animal today the
elephant has solid bones
skeleton has reached the limit of what
it can support
much bigger and it would collapse under
its own weight
but the holes in the sauropod bones
meant their skeletons were comparatively
lighter and stronger
their posture help too
[Music]
their legs are topped very firmly under
their bodies acting as pillars and those
pillars very efficiently allow the
holding up of weight Against Gravity
these sets of features together meant
that dinosaurs had a unique opportunity
to reach these huge body sizes
as these plant-eating sauropods got
bigger and bigger
had an impact on the evolution of the
hunters living alongside them
one of the reasons why gigantic
carnivores may have reached their large
sizes is actually simply because they're
trying to keep up they're trying in an
evolutionary arms race to stay in the
game to be able to take on some of these
very large herbivores
the Predators got larger so the
sorrowful larger so the Predators got
larger still
this helped the sauropods grow to these
absolutely enormous sizes that we
haven't seen since on Earth
it's unlikely we will ever see anything
like these prehistoric charms ever again
[Music]
thank you